[Musica]
sono come dicevano Tommaso evert Ho 47
anni e ho qui davanti due figli
particolarmente meravigliosamente
intensi e una moglie che prova a
conquistare dal
1984 alla quarta elementare fontana di
Villorba
ci sono ancora riuscita del tutto
e forse avete sentito il mio nome lo
diceva lo speaker e su qualche
articolo in qualche articolo di Economia
e di Finanza Infatti per mestiere mi
occupo della redazione di Bloomberg news
a Milano o magari
avete letto uno dei due libri che ho
dedicato due persone straordinarie
Sergio Marchionne e Leonardo Del Vecchio
magari qualcuno di voi questa sera è
venuto a teatro pensando che io venissi
qui a raccontarvi qualcosa di più di
queste due persone che sono riusciti a
fare la differenza Mi dispiace non sono
qui per quello oggi Anzi ehm nel caso
Chiedo agli organizzatori che chi si
lamenterà Insomma provvede provvederanno
rimborsarvi il biglietto perché io oggi
sono venuto a fare un'altra cosa qui
oggi sono venuto a parlarvi di passione
di una grande passione Perché sono
convinto che questo racconto in questi
prossimi minuti eh potrebbe arricchire
tutti noi e magari potrebbe per
convincere qualcuno di voi ad
abbracciare da seguire fino in fondo la
propria grande passione
la mia vita come potete immaginare come
quella di molti di noi è un incastro
continuo con fresco all chat delle
scuole elementari riunione delle scuole
medie sono anche rappresentante di
classe
riunioni di redazione in inglese e poi
le Breaking news che arrivano quando
meno te lo aspetti a sconvolgerti la
giornata Beh nonostante questo io
cascasse il mondo almeno una sera a
settimana quando sta diventando buio
esco di casa furtivamente tra sguardi
che sanno di disapprovazione con
miserazione
inforco una bicicletta Azzurra
attraverso la città fino a un campo
spelacchiato di periferia arrivo mi
metto i calzettoni i pantaloncini e la
maglietta le scarpe coi tacchetti il
caschetto il paradenti e gioco rugby a
47 anni almeno ci provo e allora questa
sera sono venuto qui a dirvi perché
trovare a dirvi perché lo faccio Beh noi
lo facciamo
semplicemente
perché quella è la cosa giusta da fare
ci ritroviamo così due/tre a settimana
una trentina di uomini di mezza età
diciamo non particolarmente in gran
forma fisica e anche una ventina di
mamme che cercano di imparare e di
scoprire il meraviglioso sport che fanno
i loro figli e iniziamo a correre
attorno al campo agli ordini del nostro
allenatore che è un Sergente di ferro
con le Superga stracciate e un cuore
d'oro dopo che corriamo e facciamo 4/5
giri inizia la parte atletica a quella
vera e facciamo una cosa tremenda che si
chiama Tabata 20 secondi a tutta
velocità e poi 10 secondi lenti per otto
volte per 4 minuti a quel punto sei già
abbastanza insomma arrivato e invece
inizia la prova il micidiale si chiama
bronco io non so chi l'ha inventata Ma
insomma sono degli scatti da 20 40 e 60
metri da ripetere per 1.200 metri e
cercare di farlo nel minor tempo
possibile io quando sono in forma
smagliante Ci metto 5 minuti e mezzo a
quel punto hai finito e sei morto ti
siedi un attimo Vediamo tre minuti di
riposo Prendi qualcosa da bere Fai finta
che sia uno spritz Di solito è un
Gatorade e ti chiedi veramente perché
siamo lì no E perché lo facciamo Ecco io
vi spiego perché facciamo noi siamo lì e
lo facciamo perché quello è il nostro
modo di metterci alla prova di uscire
dalla nostra zona di comfort dalla
cosiddetta comfort zone e di dare tutto
quello che abbiamo perché nel rugby non
puoi fingere quando ti arriva di fronte
un dermatologo 52enne che pesa 115 kg
incavolato nero o lo plachi o va in meta
non ci sono mezze misure quando prendi
in mano questa benedetta palla e la
cerchi di portare un passo oltre O ce la
fai e porti la palla più avanti o ti
fermano non ci sono alternative
e questo è il rugby è uno sport di
estrema verità crudo nudo E vero ed è il
motivo per cui io credo che sia giusto
farlo anche anche a quest'età e poi uno
sport che a me ha insegnato moltissimo
Prima di tutto ti insegna il rispetto
rispetto di te stesso il rispetto dei
tuoi compagni il rispetto dei tuoi
avversari e anche rispetto dell'arbitro
perché senza l'arbitro noi non potremo
giocare e poi ti segna rugby che la
diversità è importante in un 15 ideale
c'è posto per tutti quelli grossi Grandi
grossi e lenti stanno in mischia quelli
magri belli e veloci stanno sui tre
quarti poi ci sono quelli come me
piccoli un po' grossi e lenti che è un
po' un casino devono trovare il proprio
posto Io da giovane lo trovavo in prima
linea adesso in terza ogni tanto prendo
la maglia numero 9 la rubo vado dritto
non passo mai la palla Questa è una mia
caratteristica è però c'è veramente
bisogno di tutti come nella società il
rugby ti insegna che da soli valiamo
veramente poco ma Assieme possiamo
diventare fare qualcosa di importante
lui segna dalla sua regola più
importante cioè tua rugby corri con la
palla e corri in avanti ma la palla la
passi sempre all'indietro Ma cosa vuol
dire la parola passare la palla
all'indietro vuol dire che nel rugby non
fai niente senza il sostegno dei tuoi
compagni Ecco il sostegno e la parola
più importante nel nostro Sport quando
tu corri e vai contro l'avversario e
passi la palla all'indietro Devi essere
sicuro che ci sia qualcuno che sta
arrivando con la totale fiducia nel suo
compagno per andare a recuperare quel
pallone e portarlo un passo più avanti
la stessa cosa per chi arriva da dietro
quando tu arrivi da dietro hai una
fiducia totale oggi parliamo di fiducia
Sì la fiducia è totale di riuscire ad
arrivare ad aiutare il tuo compagno
questo Ci insegna il rugby e poi e poi
crea dei legami questo sport che è uno
sport di battaglia che durano per sempre
Qualcuno è anche in sala questa sera che
ha diviso con me il campo da rugby
quando tu hai giocato assieme sullo
stesso campo anche se sei stato
avversario sullo stesso campo sarai
Unito per sempre potrai sempre contare
sul suo su un tuo compagno di squadra a
prescindere da quello che sei diventato
e che diventerai ed è questo il motivo
per cui con un gruppo di compagni e
amici abbiamo creato una squadra a
Milano di mini rugby si chiama rugby
Parco Sempione dove cerchiamo di
tramandare i valori del rugby ai bambini
dai 2 ai 12 anni ma quali sono Allora
questi valori Quali sono le regole di
base del nostro Sport Beh i principi
sono molto semplici Il primo è avanzare
Come direbbero i madness One Step Beyond
e poi pressare pressare vuol dire
metterci sempre e il massimo del tuo
impegno poi continuità Chi si ferma è
perduto e ovviamente sostenere
continuità che si ferma è perduto è uno
sport che ti chiede tantissimo È un
certo punto spesso ti ritrovi mai più a
me succede Mi trovo in mezzo al campo
dico adesso non ce la faccio più allora
mi parte in testa una canzone di Vinicio
Capossela che a un certo punto dice se
non hai dato tutto non hai dato ancora E
allora quando a me parte questa canzone
in testa trovo sempre un briciolo di
energia di più per provare e continuare
a giocare e non fermarmi neanche quella
volta neanche se abbiamo quasi 50 anni
neanche se quando ho iniziato 30 anni fa
con una maglietta rossa in un campo qua
vicino Mai avrei pensato che a 50 anni
invece di andare a bere un aperitivo il
giovedì sera vado in bicicletta a
giocare a rugby in un campo di eh
periferia ma la verità è che questo
sport a me ha dato molto di più di
quello che io ho dato eh al mio sport e
poi ci sono due momenti due momenti che
per me valgono tutto e sono forse le
vere ragioni per cui tutti noi
continuiamo a giocare
e scendiamo in campo Il primo è il
momento più bello Sta per iniziare la
partita cioè il mio compagno in mezzo al
campo che sta per calciare il drop c'è
un arbitro col fischietto in bocca non
ancora fischiato noi della mischia Siamo
tutti da una parte alziamo il braccio
perché quella palla la vogliamo andare a
prendere Beh in quel momento lì
può succedere di tutto in quel momento
lì è ancora tutto possibile Noi siamo in
15 e loro sono in 15 di solito gli altri
15 sono sempre più grossi più forti più
fisicati e più belli hanno anche le
maglie più pulite ma questo è un altro
discorso io ogni volta ci credo prima
che inizi ogni partita Io sono convinto
che noi quella partita la vinceremo e ci
credo sempre a prescindere da tutto è
quel momento in cui tutto È veramente
possibile ci credo Quando gioco io e
sono talmente illuso che ci credo ogni
volta che giocano anche i ragazzi dei
nazionale con la maglia azzurra Suona
l'inno io mi commuovo ogni volta e ogni
volta quando sta per fischiare l'arbitro
sono convinto cominceremo contro
chiunque anche contro gli All Blacks
quella volta che succede una gran festa
succede poco però quella volta che
succede una gran festa perché poi quando
inizia a giocare vincerò perdere non ha
il fine del nostro Sport Io gioco sempre
per vincere non non non pensate che sia
al contrario gioco per vincere anche
quando gioco a rubamazzetto con mio
figlio con mio figlio però la verità è
che quando giocherei rugby tu giochi per
fare la cosa giusta perché al di là di
quello che si crede in giro che rugby
sia uno sport ehm per diciamo persone
ignoranti che hanno voglia di andare a
fare l'autoscontro nel rugby oltre a
tutti questi principi il prevale il
principio di utilità vuol dire che tu in
campo devi fare la cosa giusta al
momento giusto solo così sei utile alla
tua squadra che tipo da potrà dare
sostegno quando sei da solo uno dei
gravi errori che un allenatore non ti
vuole mai veder fare è quello di
isolarti pensate nel rugby L'importante
è sostegno ed è sbagliato isolarti E
allora quando tu dai tutto e quando hai
dato veramente tutto e l'arbitro fischia
alla fine se hai vinto sei perso Forse
non è quella la cosa più importante in
quel momento lì poi la partita finisce
Finalmente sta per arrivare il terzo
tempo l'arbitro fischia ci troviamo in
mezzo al campo Ci troviamo in mezzo al
campo abbiamo da una parte i vincitori
Creiamo un corridoio gli sconfitti per
ringraziare e salutare i vincitori e poi
viceversa lo stesso facciamo con
l'arbitro e poi arriva l'altro momento
che per me è fondamentale e che spiega
perché tutto questo ha senso è il
momento nostro come sarà il momento
nostro ehm questa sera quindi Vi
chiederò alla fine anche un po' di
collaborazione è il momento in cui noi
15 che abbiamo giocato ci mettiamo tutti
attorno assieme e Formiamo un cerchio lo
facciamo prima dell'inizio e alla fine
di ogni partita quello è un momento che
è solo ed esclusivamente nostro ci
abbracciamo e ci guardiamo negli occhi e
in quel momento lì
nessuno può mentire un momento di
estrema verità siamo tutti assieme sono
i 15 che hanno giocato ci sono
infortunati che non sono entrati ci sono
quelli che sono stati in panchina che
non hanno giocato Ma che sono parte
fondamentale del gruppo e poi come
diciamo noi ci sono anche i nostri
compagni che hanno passato la palla e
magari non ci sono più e ci guardano
dall'alto Allora ci mettiamo lì ci
guardiamo ci guardiamo negli occhi Ecco
se vi posso lasciare con un consiglio vi
consiglio di farlo anche voi guardatevi
negli occhi ma anche va bene anche lo
specchio guardatevi negli occhi e dal
vostro sguardo cercate di capire se
quello è stato un tempo ben speso Ecco
io ho la mia piccola ricetta che dovrai
lasciare per me
è stato un tempo ben speso se uno hai
seguito e hai avuto il coraggio di
seguire una tua passione Qualunque essa
sia Senza nessun secondo fine se non
proprio quello di seguire la propria
passione due se hai dato tutto e sei
uscito dalla tua zona di comfort non è
mai troppo tardi per giocare a rugby non
è mai troppo tardi per provare qualcosa
di nuovo dipende solo da noi vivere e
non lasciarci vivere terzo se hai capito
l'importanza che da soli come individui
alla fine valiamo veramente poco noi
valiamo solo in quanto parte di una
comunità e poi come dicevo se hai dato
tutto come diceva anche il buon Vinicio
Capossela Beh allora Secondo me se tu
hai risposto a tutte queste domande
quando ti sei guardato negli occhi
allora sì che siamo una squadra E allora
come facciamo noi ci possiamo salutare
con quello che è il nostro saluto Ogni
squadra di rugby al suo saluto quando
stringe nel cerchio Allora io vi chiedo
di fare assieme a me per chiudere questa
questa chiacchierata il nostro saluto
rugbistico quello della mia squadra di
rugby fa così noi ci chiamiamo Idra Gold
il saluto è così adesso però mi
raccomando bisogna in collaborazione se
no lo dobbiamo vedere in un video non è
bello uguale Allora io dico Idra Gold
Idra Gold e poi tutti assieme dobbiamo
dire cui cui Uni E manigolda siete
pronti
Ah è importante eh Non mi fate fare
figuracce in casa Treviso per piacere la
facciamo Siamo pronti Eh la faccio io
faccio tutti assieme I dragoni Idra Gold
quei [ __ ] e mani Gold Grazie
[Applauso]